in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions JP and
Beth are with us hey guys how are you
today
welcome welcome so you brought the whole
crew to do it that free scream you did
awesome where you guys live
say Germans are very cool good for you
so welcome to Nashville so how much debt
have you paid off
we paid off just over $130,000 excellent
making what kind of money 75 75 a year
during that time and how long did it
take you to do that we it took us six
years and one month it's a bit of a run
way to go you guys okay you stuck with
it that's awesome so um what kind of
debt was the hundred and thirty thousand
oh we had a little bit of everything
thing cars student loans our house is
paid off now oh the house is part of
house everything okay very good how much
of the hundred thirty thousand was your
home it was 64 so half of it all right
very good and the cars and student loans
and what else credit cards hmm lawn
mower of course yeah so what happened
six years and one month ago they caused
you to go on this journey and tell me
the story well we looked up one day and
realized that we were making entirely
too much money to be as broke as we were
and decided that we needed to amputate
the Jaguar and get on a plan and so we
had been listening to you on the radio
and it was kind of one of those things
well this guy's a little crazy and then
the more we started listening the more
it made sense and so we started on a
budget we got rid of the Jag and we were
rolling and that was in 2009 April of
2009 and then September of 2009 our
oldest here was diagnosed with leukemia
and so we stopped and we freaked out a
little bit and then when we decided that
we could breathe again we started again
in 2010 so of course yeah you're
supposed to freak out that's how that
works
yeah I would have freaked out so it
looks like she's doing pretty good she
is great what's her name and how old is
she Harley Harley is how old 9 to 12 12
and so what's the prognosis how's the
how's it going well it she just had her
last chemo yesterday she relapsed in
2013 and did another 2 years and 4
months worth of treatment and last chemo
was last night
whoa and then you end up in Nashville
today wow you're a trouper kiddo
way to go so we're gonna get it this
time right there we go we're done that's
it
I love it well good good for you guys
yeah that's a little bit of a little
bump in the road while you're doing this
that kind of defines everything for a
little while when you're fighting that
doesn't it it does put the brakes on all
of it yeah yeah and turn and take care
of her that's what you should do and
that's what you did so I'm very cool and
then I as you a band flow with the fight
on that you're able to continue the
attack on the debt exactly
way to go Wow so whose idea was this
when you first got started actually my
dad's sitting over here they came with
us today and when I was a teenager he he
gave me this book Larry briquettes how
to manage your money yeah and right like
every intelligent teenager I stuck it on
a shelf and ignored it sure went into
debt and then we had to go through all
this stuff so but all that stuff started
to come back and so they were kind of an
inspiration to us and going down this
road and and we just had too much money
coming in for for what we actually had
on hand what was that really ours so
Beth was listening to radio and came
home started talking about it you go
that sounds like my dad yeah kind of
that's good that's good it's good to
have good parents that are smart indeed
it's a fun thing and Larry Burkett what
a wonderful one wonderful foundation for
your family to have the biblical
foundation on handling money way to go
you guys how does it feel to have no
house payment you're weird
it's great weird is good is awesome now
tell me your other children's names and
ages this is Riley and she's 11 and
Delaney is 8 and John is 6 all right oh
very cool congratulations you guys now
have the kids been practicing there
definitely have because I mean kids
y'all got to know the people on YouTube
they rate you on how good your debt-free
Scream is so you got to be like yelling
loud it's party time
you don't have a house payment you don't
even know what that means yet but it's
gonna be huge for you means you go to
college without any debt it means you're
gonna have an awesome life going forward
your mom and dad are gonna get rich and
they're going to be very very generous
people it's going to be incredible so
I'm proud of you guys congratulations
thank you
what a tough tough fight to go through
with leukemia and going through $130,000
for the dead in six years and one month
it's got to feel great
oh yeah absolutely got to feel great and
what up irony that her last chemo is
yesterday and then your hairdo it's
almost like okay that's all behind us
now next yeah
next thing very cool I love it I love it
all right JP and Beth Harley Riley
Delaney and John a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars paid off in six years
in one month and we're gonna be
cancer-free $75,000 income count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
that's awesome man Wow
you